all right here we go all right boy do I
got something special for you today I
bet you're wondering what these babies
are books lots of them copyrighting
books because actually this got to go
that's better okay yes today I'm going
to be diving into 10 mustre copyrighting
books that whether you are a beginner or
like me El copy go you're going to want
these in your back pocket in fact I'm
going to tell you what books I recommend
why I recommend them how much they are
because there's some expensive ones on
here and where you can find them so
let's go get ready to dive into this
swimmy one today actually before we dive
in do me a very very very quick favor go
ahead and hit the like and the Subscribe
because that tells me that you want me
to continue making free videos just like
this every single week to give you that
would mean the world just take a second
hit like Subs do it are you serious are
you not even doing it that cut the cut
the video this got thank you thank you
for doing that all right now that that's
out of the way let's dive into our books
which by the way are in no particular
order we're going to look at them one by
one and then may have some honorable
recommendations at the end and a gift so
if you stick around I'm going to give
you a gift at the end let's dive into
the first book that I recommend the
first book that I recommend is on my
Kindle
and it's on my Kindle because it is
$630 on the paperback version so I
bought it on Kindle it is called great
leads by Michael Masterson he has a
co-author as well but on the Kindle you
could get this book for about $9 and
here's why I recommend this book I
recommend this book because it teaches
you the Eugene Schwarz Market awareness
funnel that typically you would have to
pay a very chunky price to get the
Eugene Schwarz book and I'll talk about
that book a little bit later but for
nine bucks you can learn everything that
you need to learn about the market
awareness funnel as well as how to write
great headlines and great intro
paragraphs which if you're new to
copyrighting 80% of your readers will
only read your headlines and about 60%
will read your intro paragraph and then
beyond that it really starts to tank so
unless you've got head lines and intro
paragraphs called leads down then you're
really going to struggle as a copywriter
so this book I highly recommend if you
have a Kindle grab it if not you're
going to be paying a chunky price for
this one but even at $630 I know it
sounds crazy but it might actually be
worth it if you're doing a lot of
copyrighting books so I highly recommend
that one on my Kindle the second book
that I recommend is candidly also on my
Kindle I kind of like to read on this
thing at night it is called advertising
headlines that will make you rich by
David garfinkle now you don't have to
buy this on the Kindle I just happen to
buy it on the Kindle so I don't have
like a physical book to do really sexy
b-roll and show you it all but it's 16
bucks whether you grab it on paperback
or on the Kindle I recommend this book
because of the first point that I said
in great leads that 80% of your readers
will only read your headline in fact
this is more crucial than I think people
actually give it credit for meaning if
you understand headlines you could write
sales letters you could write Twitter
copy LinkedIn copy email subject lines
YouTube thumbnails you can write
practically anything it is truly
mastering the art of capturing attention
so if you're going to get into
copywriting and you don't spend an
extensive amount of time studying and
mastering headlines even if you've been
doing copywriting for 10 years this is a
book that will not only show you the
greatest performing headlines of all
times but David Garf fingle actually
breaks down the psychology behind why
they work so instead of just blatantly
swiping the headlines you could actually
create your own based on the
understanding of what makes a great
headline highly recommend big bang for
your bucket $16 the next book that I'm
recommending is the copywriters handbook
by Robert blide the reason I'm
recommending this sucker right here and
it is thick it is 400 50 freaking pages
but the reason I like this book is
because it's so versatile he goes over
everything in this book he talks about
how to write Direct Mail he talks about
emails Google ads Facebook ads uh sales
landing pages he literally talks about
copywriting in every single facet social
media all of it it's really versatile it
is a little dry right it's a it's very
ones and zeros very typical Robert blide
be honest but it's so wicked smart and
versatile that if you need to write a
lot of different styles of copy and you
need the best way of doing each of them
really well and just be a very versatile
monster in copyrighting you can't really
beat this especially at The Banger price
of
$10 Link in the description below for
all these books if you remember go ahead
and grab this one if you need to be
really versatile highly recommend how
about we shake things up a bit with this
next one and that is quick copyrighting
system by Clayton make piece now may
notice this isn't a folder it's because
I got I got this off eBay to be honest
because it is so hard to find this thing
now I did find it on Gary halpert's
website to a salesletter where you can
buy it directly but no lie this is one
of them expensive ones by expensive I
mean
14497 in the US that's almost
$1,500 you're like 1,500 for a book yes
but you have to understand this is more
a course than it is a book it just
happens to be printed again I got mine
on eBay for a lot cheaper than that I I
just looked and I don't see any right
now but you can go on eBay and see if
anybody's selling these and this isn't
even like the legit version this I think
I mean this guy really but he printed it
I mean he found it reprinted it hand
copied it and mailed it to me and it's
the legit it's a legit copy it's just
not from clay make piece but yeah that
that's some that's some in and around
dirty dirty right there but the reason I
highly recommend this book or this
course however you want to see it in the
investment is because if you are only
going to buy one thing off of this
entire list it should be this one and
the reason it is is because it literally
is from beginner to the most advanced he
goes over
every now he does it from a perspective
of direct mail cuz Clayton make piece
was one of the highest paid copy riters
in direct mail rest in peace my brother
but even from that perspective he breaks
down the psychology he breaks down the
emotion and that's probably the
strongest part of this course is you
start to understand why people
emotionally respond to your copy and how
to write copy that is emotionally driven
which will make you a lot more money but
overall it is literally a 0 to 100 start
to finish you would never need to read
another resource of copyrighting ever
again in your life you could just read
this one thing 10 times times never read
anything and be incredibly wealthy so
that is why it's on this list it is that
good it is that in-depth and is that
helpful and while we're at it how about
another expensive
one infotainment jackpot this is by Ben
settle one of my favorite copywriters
ever been is um widely known as an email
copywriter but he really made his way on
sales letters but this one is definitely
for the email copyrighters and you know
for the sales letters if you want but
infotainment jackpot this is why I
recommend it I recommend it because you
learn so much about how to not be boring
in copyrighting one of the biggest
problems in the copyrighting world
especially in 2024 2025 moving on where
people have Tik Tok and they have
YouTube and they have all these other
platforms that entertain them this book
teaches you how to be entertaining in
your copy to make your copy addictive to
make it really fun to read and you're
going to notice that as a theme in some
of my favorite books that I'm
recommended because if your copy isn't
fun to read they won't read it now this
book does slap in at a nice 391 so it
ain't exactly the cheapest thing on the
list but if you really become an
entertaining copywriter in your
storytelling and the way that you
connect words and your power words and
just the fun ways of writing especially
for email copywriters like me then this
is well worth the price because it'll
keep your readers coming back for more
and and it'll help you sell a lot more
than 391 that's for sure just by
learning how to entertain through your
writing highly recommend the next book
that I want to recommend is scientific
advertising by Claude Hopkins if you
don't know who Claude Hopkins is he is
the founding father of modernday
advertising I.E copyrighting as well he
is the person that back in the day in
the 30s and the 40s figured out that
copyrighting is sales in print they were
doing advertising in the 20s 30s 40s
without knowing hey what like what
actually makes somebody buy like what is
persuasive about the way that you write
words well Claude Hopkins is the one
that figured it out and he's the one
that put together a book called
scientific advertising the one that I'm
recommending you this is published in
the 40s so you might read this and be
like w this is old yeah it's old it's
almost 100 years old but in that it is
so good because it is stripped away from
all the fluff that you get in
copyrighting today which is actually the
number one reason why I recommend this
book is because it's pure fundamentals I
mean it is copyrighting at its Essence
in fact David Ogie used to say in his
agency that you will not write a lick of
copy for me until you have read
scientific advertising seven times now
there's a catch to the version that I
have I have my life in advertising and
scien ific advertising so it's two books
in one I like this copy better because I
get to learn about Claude Hopkins and
you're going to want to learn about his
life and how he got to where he is it's
very interesting which makes the
fundamentals that more impactful highly
recommend if you want to strip
everything away and just understand copy
at its core the price for this sucker is
12 bucks nothing cost you nothing learn
a ton the next book that we are going to
look at is cash vertising by Drew Eric
Whitman so I'm not going to lie I picked
up this book very late in the
copyrighting game I was didn't even know
it existed and then just about a year
ago I came across it and figured out
whoa this is one of the most valuable
copyrighting books in the entire
industry at just 16 bucks he Dives
really deep into 100 psychological ways
to be more persuasive with your copy he
talks about emotions he talks about
desire he talks about simplifying your
language and words and all these kinds
of it's really like a tips and tricks
little neat book now granted it is not a
fun read I mean it is literally just
very practical uh you I mean you're
going to drag through it a little bit
but it is so packed with knowledge I you
would be foolish not to pick this up in
fact this is actually one of the first
books I highly recommend to a lot of
people just getting into copyrighting so
they can understand the persu Ive side
but definitely a banger if you don't
have it in your library speaking of very
dry hard to get through books this one
is not one of them this is very good
copy by my friend Eddie schaner in fact
he started the website called very good
copy.com he has a fantastic newsletter
and this one is literally I mean the
subtitle is so clear 207 micr lessons on
thinking and writing like a copywriter
uh this is not a small book this is over
400 pages I mean it's like 420 pages but
it reads like it's maybe 100 Pages it's
so well written it's shockingly short
chapters I mean it's one to two to three
pages per chapter per micro lesson very
simple to get through it's like if Seth
Goden and Austin Cleon had a
copyrighting baby and they wrote this
book amazing and it's so fun to read I
mean you'll dig through it's very
storytelling and and you'll just really
blow through it and pick up a lot of
copyrighting golden nuggets along the
way now this isn't some like lesson one
lesson two lesson three it's not like
that at all it is literally just really
good bite-sized lessons that you can
pick up along your reading Journey but
the reason I highly recommend it so much
is because it's so easy to read that
often times copywriters put put great
books down because they just got to
track through them this is not one of
them you would easily blow through all
400 pages in a weekend tops highly
recommend 25 bucks on Amazon pick it up
you're going to enjoy this one for our
next one how about a copyrighting look
that isn't a copyrighting book
storyworthy storyworthy by Matthew dicks
this book is has been so impactful to my
copywriting that I want to burn some of
my other copyrighting books but this
isn't one of them Matthew dicks really
breaks down a lot of tips templates and
ideas that help you write better stories
which ding ding is at the essence of
great copy because if you want people to
read your copy whether it's an ad
whether it's an email a sales page
whatever it is if you tell great stories
you will have them captivated for hours
okay what makes a great ad is it doesn't
feel like an ad that's the best part and
when you can write great stories that
don't feel like ads you will become more
persuasive and infinitely better
copywriter so I would highly recommend
this book first off it's very
entertaining obviously it's jam-packed
full of stories I mean what kind of
Storytelling book would this be if it
didn't have a ton of stories it's got a
bunch of them that you can really enjoy
it's 15 bucks on Amazon super cheap
highly practical I mean one of the first
books anybody should read I recommend
just everybody read this book whether
you're a copyright or not highly
recommend super fun you'll enjoy it and
finally for the last of the 10 and then
we'll get on to some honorable mentions
ooh the man himself joh Carlton kickass
copyrighting Secrets now again this is
another binder one I didn't get this off
eBay I actually bought this off the link
in the description below uh but I bought
the PDF and then I just printed it
myself I mean it is it is a thick boy
I've gone through this one uh four or
five times this is a classic that John
Carlton wrote and one of the reasons I
recommend it so much is because how
stupid simple he makes copyrighting he
takes the biggest concepts of
copyrighting and really Bears it down on
the Basic Essentials that you need to
know and how to execute them with
Excellence as fast as possible like
literally if you're looking to get good
fast this is it this is the book that I
mean I could read this five more times
and still not be bored because it's very
entertaining it's very well written his
personality is hilarious and it makes
you a lot of money I mean he literally
puts it operation money suck how to suck
as much money from your clients your
customers as much as possible it really
is a revenue generating Speed Demon of a
copyrighting book and only 50 bucks now
if you're gawking at 50 bucks because
some of these other books are $10 and
$15 think about the money you will make
from the books you invest in this one
you could definitely grab today
instantly have it on PDF read it on a
computer print it out like I do and
instantly make your money back by the
end of the week I promise you this is
the fastest way to become a good
copywriter highly recommend all right
how about some honorable mention
starting
with the ad we copyrighting handbook by
Joe sugerman so love this book
especially for beginners if if you don't
know where to start this a great place
to start especially at a very cheap
price so this book you can get on Amazon
for $15 it's a great starter book starts
you off from like if you know nothing
all the way to hey I know a good decent
bit by the end of this book teaches you
headlines body copy products all this
stuff right research gives you a lot of
ideas the reason I don't have it in my
top 10 is because it's a little bit of a
drag to read it's it's not that it's too
long it's yeah it's about 350 pages but
some of it just feels like he goes
really in depth into topics and ideas
that aren't as relevant today uh
sometimes direct mail or product
research that are just really old
products and things like that and you
can definitely learn something from it
but it's it's like a valley right you
got to get through those like really
like oh man this is this is really
boring all the way to the like oh this
is really juicy so he has boring juicy
boring juicy but honestly for the for
the price and the value and how good it
is I would still put it up in my
honorable mentions here's an honorable
mention that you are going to hate and
love at the same time copy slacker by
Ben settle so that other expensive book
infotainment jackpot that I showed you a
little bit ago holds not a candle to
this puppy right here which is exactly
why this is not on my top 10 list
otherwise it would be this book is
824 I just heard the wind leave your
lungs don't crap a brick my guy okay
relax yes it is expensive but let me
explain why it's so good so in this book
Ben walks through his fstep formula that
he uses to write sales letters very fast
and in fact I never seen a salesletter
formula so simple as this one including
market research bullet riding headlines
leads closing the whole gamut he covers
in here and then that's not even the
best part the best part is in the back
of this thing
he includes 50 of his best sales letters
and on like 10 of them he does a line by
line breakdown of how he wrote it do you
understand how valuable that is I mean
to get anything close to what I would
consider a mentorship in copyrighting
under a grand this book is insanely
jam-packed I mean it is how long is this
this is like 900 Pages by the way this
book is if you are writing sales letters
or website landing page letters uh
direct mail letters and you don't have
this book I think you're missing out on
a ton of potential cashola the green
stuff to put in your pockets again not a
ton of people are writing sales letters
like they used to nowadays and it's very
expensive which is why it goes on an
honorable mention but one of my personal
favorites and the last honorable mention
that we need to talk about today
is breakthrough advertising Eugene
Schwarz I am so honored to own a copy of
this book first off it used to go for a
whopping
like, because nobody could ever find it
and it used to be the most robbed book
from the public library now they don't
even have them in public libraries but
with the link in the description below
you can get it from Titans marketing for
$125 which is not cheap but not
necessarily expensive and you could dive
into one of the most infamous books on
copyrighting now you can get um the core
of this book the core of the information
in the book called great leads that I
recommended in the beginning of this
video so you can get kind of the essence
but this is like the Deep dive the truth
behind what you're learning he really
dives into desire and knowing who your
target audience is he dives into
headlines and a lot of Concepts that you
just would have you'd have to read this
book 10 times to to truly get its worth
I think I've gone through it um two or
three times by now but I still every
time I open it up I mean I just have
different highlights in different colors
because I've just learned something
different every single time now the one
con with this book is it is thick it is
thick and dry now it's not thick in
Pages it's maybe 200 something Pages
yeah it's like yeah 250 pages but the
content is so rich and so deep that I
barely get through a few pages before
I'm like oh what and it is dry it is not
there's not a lot of Storytelling it's
not a fun read but it is informative as
heck and honestly it's just a great book
to have in your collection uh any
copywriter you see this on the wall and
you're like my guy well that wraps us up
that wraps us up with the 10 mustre
copyrighting books as of right now I'll
do another one of these if you guys want
and a few honorable mentions but how
about something for free okay everybody
likes free stuff so I am giving you
copyrighting Catalyst 63 cash cow
copyrighting tips that you can access
and read today all you got to do is hit
the link in the description below for
copyrighting Catalyst put your email in
and I will instantly free email it to
you you can dive into every single tip
starting right now it takes about 90
seconds to read per tip so you can
literally have it done in an hour and
you can learn a ton about copyrighting
it's like a free crash course from me
your boy El copy go and that's it I hope
you enjoyed that there is a free gift
for you if you have loved this video
please like And subscribe to the channel
tells me that you love them and you want
me to keep making videos because if you
don't subscribe I'm just kidding I'll
keep making videos I really like making
these videos and I hope you enjoy them
as well so please like And subscribe
before you head out I hope you have a
wonderful day El copygo I will catch you
on the next time I'm going to see you on
the next one okay
all right bye bye muchacho okay see you
next time okay bye oh my God I got to
clean up all these books oh how am I
gonna do that this gonna take forever